and now on to the gop's 2024
prospects the media's favorite
Republican that's the focus of tonight's
angle everybody wants to move away from
Ukraine they'll want to move away from
Israel a year from now America can never
be so arrogant to think we don't need
friends after 911 we needed a lot of
friends now is the time to get
Partnerships you know I stood on the
salimon boulevard bridge and watched
thousands of Venezuelans cross in the
for hours in the hot sun holding their
babies they were fleeing socialism and
begging for
Freedom now after last last night's
debate one conclusion is undeniable the
media wants Nikki Haley as the GOP
nominee look at these headlines from
Politico most of their reporters agreed
Nikki Haley had the best night and in a
tweet Nikki Haley's Ascension in the
2024 primary was hard to ignore and High
Praise over at the New York Times too
they're saying Haley won all three
debates
and let's not forget
MSNBC they're in as about as much love
as they can be with a republican whose
last name isn't Bush Cheney kinar or
Romney Nikki Haley who I do like as a
candidate because she's got some spark
Nikki Haley who you know was deemed as
having a pretty good night she has had a
couple good debates in a row she showed
the kind of determination and Steely uh
I think uh strength it needs to go up
against uh foreign adversaries like
Putin H well it's nice to get good press
I do get that but politically this is
suicide for Nikki Haley there's no
future in the Republican party for
someone who's been endorsed by Politico
and the New York Times now Nikki hilly
can be a media hero or she can be a
leader in the GOP but she cannot be both
so if Nikki hilly wants to win GOP
support she has to explain how she's
just not the second coming of the bushes
and L Cheney but right now it appears
from listening to her last night at
least that she is otherwise the media
wouldn't be rallying to her but the fact
is she's relentlessly proar which in a
matchup with Biden would allow him to
take the peace Lane that's great for
Biden could she went over the Trump
voters hard to see how she could do that
but one idea I guess would be for her to
travel to a Battleground State and then
pick a fight over a cause that actually
makes the media mad how about that it's
my view after last night as it has been
in every debate that Ronda santis
emerges strongest this is because he has
the most experience as a successful
chief executive along with a clear
populist message that voters are aligned
with I'm going to stop The Invasion cold
I am going to deport people who came
illegally it's a full spectrum approach
to be able to fend China off yes
military deterrence yes economic
decoupling but also their role in our
culture if we don't if we ignore that
we're not going to be able to win the
fight he's the only one you can actually
see as presidential material someone you
know would make good decisions if Trump
somehow stumbles but there's no sign yet
that that's happening and that's the
angle hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere
else